[Music]
i know that first of all uh you are
canadian you're from yeah and i love
canadians and i love all of canada
they've always been very good to me um
i'm guessing you travel a lot then you
commute almost between where canada and
where in canada uh in toronto so you go
from toronto to l.a back every three
weeks yeah we have some toronto here
that's good
thank you
they're all they're all dressed as
mounties in the back
um yeah i'm flying a lot does that get
exhausting you do you
yeah i've never liked flying but i you
know i'm sort of i'm getting over it a
little bit but my whole thing is like
i like to clock how everyone's doing
when i get on the plane you know what i
mean like i like to get eyes on the
captain i like to see how he's doing
does he look hungover does he look ill
is he all right then i clocked the
stewardess i checked them out see if
they're do you look at other passengers
like
recently actually which is always a good
way to distract yourself from the fear
of flying is when you can catch eyes
with someone who is a little awkward
like i was sitting next to a woman who
actually was eating pudding
at a without a spoon and refused to have
a spoon and was slurping it out of the
cup so it's like this
thing
and i was like this really but what why
was she spoon did they offered her a
spoon and she said well no this is my
way no me i would like i would like this
i was like can wait can we get her this
a spoon oh no no i don't want a spoon
since you think i was like okay she
doesn't want a spoon and then the guy
across from her was like this
just doing that to her he did not want
to see it i wasn't getting grossed out
by it but i i was like i find it erotic
myself really like oh
i'll be there watching uh
yeah that was fantastic
that's not what i was imagining at all
but that was amazing
will you eat pudding for me more often
[Laughter]
i like anyone tuning in at that moment
uh
you are dating a hockey player back in
toronto that is a very violent dangerous
sport does this worry you are you
worried about your boyfriend no i mean i
i he knows what he's doing but i do get
uh sometimes it gets it gets scary i
mean this year we had a little bit of a
thing where i was actually at the game
and he got hit in the face with um
with a with a puck
um got it in the face yeah i blocked a
shot and i was i was really really upset
run back down and wait for the doctors
to hear if he's okay and which is a very
you know tense moment and and the doc
comes out and said okay alicia you know
we're gonna come back and go see him and
just you know
brace yourself make sure you're you know
brace yourself well he said he doesn't
look good i mean he doesn't look good
but he's fine he's fine so i was like
thank god he's fine but like you know
stay strong don't freak him out his face
don't freak him out he has no face
so they said you know just be just don't
freak him out and
i got this i don't you know come around
the corner jesus
he had a big
bad guys and blood coming out of his
mouth oh my gosh it looks great
[Music]
a little sick about it he had a puck
coming out of his head you look good
that's fine
my mouth's watering
it out that's what that is i don't know
i thought that was a duck call
[Applause]
the two of us are like mating calls
[Laughter]
is weird i'm sorry it's this show